give me the power i beg of you
to hide deep inside now here i reside
cause i died
but i'm still gonna kill you
[Music]
usa and sci-fi bring you an evil too
great for just one network chucky series
premieres october 12th
everyone has a halloween they'll always
remember
and this
is jake's
[Music]
jake you into vintage no i'm in the
retro oh what's the difference about 10
bucks fair enough
[Music]
look at that someone took the butcher
knife
[Music]
hi
i'm chuckie you want to play
[Music]
jake
are you okay i can't stand this other
blood
[ __ ]
oh no jake that isn't quite right
happening jake
you used to have friends
don't forget your boy toy
[Applause] [Music]
okay
it's contagious isn't it laughing at
people
well guess what and now the joke's on
you
hi
i'm chuck
and i'm your friend to the end
what did you do
mommy says real killing is bad yeah well
mommy's foolish
look around you it's the world series of
slaughter
[Music]
did you feel that
everywhere jake wheeler goes death seems
to follow
creepy doll just creeps me the hell out
it's kill or be killed everybody's gotta
choose
what's going on with it
you wouldn't believe me if i told you
chucky
he's gone dude you have a secret style
problem if you only know
[Music]
hey kid
i'm gonna go kill your sister
wanna come are you sleepy
you snooze you lose
you